هذه هي سفينة HMS alderia، وهي
سفينة حربية سعودية على وشك المغادرة من هنا
في جدة في الوجه الملكي للقاعدة البحرية
إلى ميناء سيدان، إنها رحلة تستغرق من 10 إلى 12 ساعة
عبر البحر الأحمر لإجلاء
المزيد من الأشخاص من السودان، هذه واحدة من
الجيش السعودي ولكن هناك أيضًا
سفن تجارية تفعل الشيء نفسه على
وشك الوصول إلى الميناء هنا في
جدة وحتى الآن يقول السعوديون أنه
تم إجلاء حوالي 3000 شخص من فورت السودان،
فقط حوالي 100 من العملية.  كانوا
مواطنين سعوديين أتوا من ثمانية إلى
دول مختلفة بما في ذلك الولايات المتحدة والمملكة
المتحدة وأستراليا وكندا وكينيا ودول
من جميع أنحاء العالم. تعد المملكة العربية السعودية
لاعبًا دبلوماسيًا رئيسيًا في السودان وهي
جزء مما يسمى بالرباعية التي
تضم الولايات المتحدة والمملكة المتحدة
والإمارات العربية المتحدة، لذلك عندما يأتي هؤلاء الأشخاص إلى
هنا يتلقون صليبًا من هناك
حيث يتم إعطاؤهم الطعام وإرساله إلى
الفنادق عند الضرورة حتى يتمكنوا من
ترتيب ترتيبات السفر النهائية أو
أي شيء آخر سيذهبون إليه